vamos a continuar con nuestra tabla de
transformadas de la plaza y en esta
ocasión va a ser una transformada
bastante densa así que tengo que
concentrarme para no equivocarme digamos
que quiero hacer la transformada de la
plaza de esta que es bastante útil bueno
de hecho todas son útiles les avisaré
cuando alguna no sea útil queremos
encontrar la transformada de la plaza de
el seno
de a porter y recordemos la definición
de la transformada de la plaza que es la
integral impropia de 0 a infinito y
bueno recordemos que la transformada de
la plaza es una herramienta que es
bastante útil y de esto hablaremos más
adelante entonces es la integral
impropia de 0 a infinito de ala menos st
x lo que sea que tenemos dentro de los
corchetes en este caso seno de aporte de
t y ahora tenemos que regresar y
encontrar nuestra neurona para hacer las
integrales por partes en mi cerebro esta
neurona siempre desaparece por lo que
voy a desglosar la integración por
partes que es algo que no les recomiendo
que hagan siempre es mejor que si van a
tener un examen recuerden que la
integración por partes viene de la
derivada de un producto así que esto lo
voy a hacer en este lado la regla de
producto nos dice que si tengo a un por
de ambas son funciones y quiero sacar la
derivada con respecto
de ambas ambas funciones están con
respecto a t va a ser igual a la
derivada de la primera función por la
segunda función más la primera función
multiplicada por la derivada de la
segunda función y ahora voy a integrar
ambas partes tenemos que por b va a ser
igual a la integral de la derivada de un
x b más la integral de 1 por la derivada
de b o b prima esto me ayuda a
recordarlo y ahora vamos a restar esta
integral de esta otra parte vamos a
cambiar de color esta integral la
integral de prima de su prima b va a ser
igual a o por b menos la integral de un
x de prima por de prima claro que todas
esas funciones son dt pero yo tenía que
escribir esto en una orilla de mi
cuaderno para poder acordarme de todas
las integrales y derivadas que siempre
se me estaban olvidando una forma de
memorizar esto es decir bueno tengo
la integral de la derivada de la primera
función multiplicada por la segunda
función y eso es igual a ambas funciones
multiplicadas menos la integral reversa
o decir la integral de la que la primera
función que era derivada bueno ahora va
a estar normal va a ser multiplicada por
la segunda función que va a estar
derivada pero bueno bueno vamos a
enfocarnos a nuestro problema actual que
es esta transformada y aquí podemos
decir que cualquiera de estas sea la
función y la función b entonces vamos a
decir que su prima va a ser va a ser
igual
a la menos st y por lo tanto la función
va a ser la anti derivada que es menos 1
entre s x
a la menos siete y bueno
recordemos que este problema va a ser un
problema de integración por partes doble
voy a definir de una vez que está
transformada de laplace va a ser igual
creo que hice un problema muy parecido a
éste cuando se vio el tema de
integración por partes pero bueno vamos
a enfocarnos en esta integración por
partes así que si está eso vamos ahora
escribir de en otro de color si esto es
su prima esta va a ser vez así que va a
ser igual a el seno de ate y cuál es de
prima a bueno va a ser algo seno de
aporte y ahora estamos listos para hacer
nuestra integral así que la transformada
de la plaza a la que llamamos ye y es lo
que queremos encontrar bueno y va a ser
igual
va a ser igual a prima por ver o la
integral de un prima por ver que es
igual a o por b
por lo que escribimos que es igual a
menos 1 entre s por y para menos
st multiplicado por el seno de a t
- la integral
y bueno debemos recordar que cuando
hacemos integrales por partes pues
podemos tener aquí integrales
indefinidas o impropias o cualquier otra
pero los límites se mantienen así que va
a ser la integral de 0 infinito de x de
prima y aquí tenemos que y es igual a
menos 1 entre s por ea la menos st y de
prima va a ser
por goce no a d
muy bien y aquí agregamos el dt y ahora
aquí tenemos otra integral densa pues
tenemos otra integral por partes y bueno
vamos a ver qué tanto podemos
simplificar esto vamos a reescribir las
cosas voy a escribir aquí ye igual a
menos o al menos ese porte entre s por
el seno de a porte menos menos pues va a
ser más va a ser más
/ s esto es una constante así que por
eso la sacamos de la integral y ahora si
va a ser la integral de 0 a infinito de
- st por el coseno de a de dt y bueno ya
tenemos simplificada nuestra integral
por partes que la voy a hacer en otro
color para que quede un poquito más
claro así y una vez más vamos a definir
nuestras o prima
su prima va a ser igual a él a la menos
ese porte así que este es su prima y uno
va a ser igual a menos uno entre s por
el ala menos act y ahora me va a ser
igual a igual a coseno de aporte
y ahora de prima va a ser igual a igual
va a ser igual a menos a por el seno de
aporte es la misma regla que hicimos en
la integral por partes anterior así que
ahora vamos a sustituir esto nuevamente
en nuestra regla hay que poner atención
porque eso está bastante denso vamos a
tener que ya va a ser igual a menos
al menos ese porte entre s por el seno
de a porte más
sobre s x
a ver integración por partes y ve que es
menos 1 entre s por el ala menos 70
por de que es co seno de la corte
menos
- la integral
de 0 al infinito
y baja ya que este problema se me está
cansando pero no importa vamos a
concentrarnos para terminarlo
de la integral de 0 infinito
y ahora tenemos un port de prima que es
menos 1 entre s por al menos 7
qué es eso
y ahora mi prima es
vamos a escribir vamos a quitar este a
cancelar este menos con el otro que
tenemos
por a por seno de a t
dt y ya como que se empieza a ver la luz
al final del túnel bueno vamos a tratar
de simplificar todo esto un poco más y
por supuesto vamos en algún momento que
tener que evaluar esto para cuando te es
igual a infinito y para cuando te bueno
no este no puede ser igual infinito para
cuando te se aproxima a infinito y para
cuando te es igual a cero
pero bueno ahorita vamos a concentrarnos
en la simplificación así que ya va a ser
igual a menos e elevado a la menos 7
entre s por seno de aporte
/ s por menos 1 / s menos a / s al
cuadrado por al menos 7 por el coseno de
a t muy bien ahora vamos a revisar que
no se nos haya ido algún error
ahora vamos a multiplicar esto por esto
y vamos a sacar todas las constantes que
es a 1 entre s así que aquí nos va a
quedar menos menos
- a cuadrada / s cuadrada por la
integral por la integral de tops me
acabo de acordar que en este momento voy
a trabajar con la integral indefinida no
voy a ver los límites ahorita con la
integral de e a la menos st por el seno
de aporte de t y bueno esto ya lo hemos
hecho antes y el truco está en la
integral por partes pero esta expresión
que están viendo aquí noten que es
exactamente la misma expresión con la
que comenzamos sólo que aquí para
mantener las cosas más simples manejamos
la integral indefinida no estuvimos
llevando los límites todo el tiempo
porque hubiera estado todavía más denso
así que aquí vamos a tener oops me acabo
de dar cuenta que me estoy quedando sin
tiempo así que vamos a continuar con
este problema tan denso en el siguiente
vídeo